nous sommes à présent avec gérald pierre
fake et médecins urgentistes bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
olivier ferrand remplace donc agnès
buzyn convient d'entendre un visiblement
très ému vous allez le regretter reste
busan nom sert que elle est touchante
quand on la voit comme ça et on a été
touché il ya deux ans quand elle a pris
deux ans et demi quand elle a pris
ministère de la santé on s'est dit tiens
médecin hospitalière qui connaît bien ce
côté sincérité comme ça spontanée le
problème c'est que depuis deux ans et
demi c'est une catastrophe le bilan
politique du ministère de la santé
depuis deux ans et demi ce sont des
hôpitaux qui sont grève des services
d'urgence qui sont en grève depuis 11
mois ce sont des plans comme ma santé
2022 qui ne répondent à aucune attente
ni de la population ni des médecins
généralistes ni des hospitaliers mille
démission de chef de service il ya à
peine un mois bref on voit bien que
depuis deux ans et demi la situation n'a
fait que s'aggraver donc le bio
politique est un mauvais bilan politique
on parle la crise du coronavirus voilà
il n'y a pas eu de crise du corps d'un
virus parce qu'il n'ya pas que
coronavirus entraîné pas de dangerosité
à date de ce virus sinon je pense qu'on
aurait été très très mal pour pouvoir le
gérer
en tout cas nous on va pas le regretter
et on va pas regretter non plus la
surdité qu'on avait au ministère de la
santé tous les syndicats sont d'accord
commun pour dire il n'y avait pas d'
écoutes qui avait pas de dialogue
donc je sais pas comment ça va se passer
sur une campagne municipale mais en tout
cas il n'y avait pas de dialogue au
ministère les dossiers ne manquent pas
en ministère de la santé il y a le
corona virus il y a cette réforme des
retraites il ya aussi la crise
évidemment de l'hôpital al'annonce fière
de ce remplacement en urgence à la tête
des ministères de la santé l'opposition
c'est évidemment prononcée elle met en
avant le fait que cette crise finalement
à la république en marche semble plus
importante pour l'exécutif que la crise
nationale comment est ce que vous vous
avez accueilli la nouvelle hier non en
fait j'ai entendu certains confrères qui
disait on nous enlève le commandant
d'un navire en pleine tempête bon et
très clairement les dossiers seront
gérées notamment le coronavirus il est
des îles et gérer pourquoi il est géré
parce qu'il est gérée par la direction
générale de la santé donc ça ne change
pas donc l'administration du ministère
ne change pas et notamment jérôme
salomon qui est directeur général de la
santé et puis surtout les gérer au
quotidien par les équipes et ça c'est
pas la ministre qui est de garder qui
prend des gardes ni aux urgences ni en
réanimation infectieuses par exemple
donc ça c'est un faux procès en revanche
quand on dit que c'est une femme
exceptionnelle un bilan exceptionnel au
ministère de la santé pardon mais le
bilan politique à la tête du ministère
de la santé
ce n'est pas un bon bilan politique donc
sur un plan purement de gestion des
dossiers depuis deux ans deux ans et
demi de dialogue syndical tout
simplement de dialogue social
là on ne va pas regretter les choses or
je suis pas sûr qu'avec olivier ferrand
les choses les choses s'améliorent mais
en tout cas on va pas regretter la tête
du ministère est de dire que c'est
mettre en péril et que la municipalité
paris est plus importante que le
coronavirus ça je pense que c'est un peu
une entourloupe politicienne mais ça n'a
pas beaucoup de sens
on le présente comme un fin connaisseur
du monde de la santé olivier ferrand
comment est ce que vous voyez ce père ce
personnage est ce qu'il peut être
l'homme de la situation sur la réforme
des retraites sur ses nombreux dossiers
de la vidéo c'est la continuité dacia
pas de changement entre agnès buzyn et
olivero et des vers en est un bon
connaisseur un médecin hospitalier c'est
un confrère
il connaît bien les problèmes de santé
et on connaît bien olivier ferrand dire
qu'on connaît bien notamment puisqu'il
c'est lui qui a défendu le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
il était le rapporteur général donc à
une continuité totale et si actuellement
et amis chefs de service pour
démissionner que les hôpitaux sont en
grève les services d'urgence en oeuvre
c'est en partie à cause de livier
veyrenc a défendu bec et ongles dans
l'hémicycle à l'assemblée nationale la
loi de finances de la sécurité sociale
avec un objectif de dépenses
d'assurance-maladie complètement au ras
des pâquerettes à 2,3 alors que les
revendications sont de l'ordre de 4%
pour faire face à la crise hospitalière
c'est lui qui défend les amendements qui
porte même son nom l'amendement de
réorientation là vous arriver aux
urgences
et puis je ne sais qui est l'accueil des
urgences va vous dire ah bah non c'est
pas une urgence retourner chez votre
médecin généraliste qui à notre sens est
un non sens déjà payé un hôpital pour
pas faire le boulot qui va faire le
boulot est ce que c'est un médecin qui
réoriente le risque médico-légal vous
rendez compte
quand on renvoie quelqu'un à la maison
on lui a dit
puis depuis des mois que cet amendement
est à côté de la plaque donc il connaît
bien l'équipe des sujets il a apporté
des réponses qui malheureusement n'était
pas les bonnes réponses donc de là à
dire que c'est l'homme de la situation
de notre point de vue ça va être je
pense compliqué en revanche c'est
l'homme de la situation en termes de
continuité et puisque rien ne changera
et les dossiers et le ministère sera
pilotée à peu près de la même manière
avec cette espèce de ligne qui est une
ligne technocratique est une ligne de
bureaucratie depuis des mois pour ne pas
dire des années c'est donc à vous
entendre c'est le statu quo qui va
perdurer à la tête du ministère de la
santé concernant donc le dossier des
retraites vous l'avez rappelé le sujet
ne lui est pas inconnu a obligé vers ans
puisqu'il venait d'être tout juste nommé
un rapporteur du volet organique de
cette réforme la réforme des retraites à
points mettrait donc fin au régime
autonome des médecins qu'est ce que ça
changerait pour vous au quotidien les
médecins libéraux pas d'égaliser à
auteuil c'est un peu le même problème
que pour les avocats une caisse autonome
finalement qui est autofinancé avec de
même avec même de l'excédent donc du
coup les médecins libéraux ça concerne
pas les hospitaliers vise m'attendais
c'est complètement injuste comme système
et la réponse c'est de dire mais il faut
que tout le monde tout le monde
participe on a beaucoup entendu parler
de justice sociale y compris la
passation de pouvoir ce matin à 10
heures la ministre ait besoin était la
ministre de la justice sociale olivier
verront reprend ses éléments de langage
mais force est de constater qu'on est
dans des éléments de langage sur le
dossier des retraites parce qu'il a été
clairement démontré qu' il y aura pas de
justice sociale et notamment beaucoup
vont perdre alors certains vont gagner
peut-être les plus pauvres et encore de
manière très marginale pourrait
peut-être bénéficier de ce nouveau
système
mais dans l'immense majorité les gens
vont gagner de quoi en avons perdre on a
l'impression que le mot justice sociale
et un peu un mot valise un mot clé comme
ça qu'il faut mettre à toutes les sauces
et c'est la même chose sur la caisse des
médecins libéraux et médecins libéraux
comme les avocats ils ont pas envie
toute leur vie de trimer d'abonder dans
une caisse et puis à la clé de se
retrouver finalement avec une retraite
qui va qui va diminuer sur toute la
pénibilité c'est un sujet là aussi qui
sera au coeur des discussions si
discussion est liée à l'assemblée
nationale la pénibilité elle est quand
même peu pris en compte sur quels
critères il ya pas que la pénibilité
physique la pénibilité psychologique
on attend aussi beaucoup ministre véran
sur la pénibilité et sur l'attractivité
des hôpitaux
le métier de soignant qui est devenu
métier extrêmement épuisant quand vous
êtes aide-soignante quand vous êtes
infirmières et que pendant des années
vous êtes quasiment cassé à la fin de
votre carrière vous attendez que cette
dernière s'arrête rapidement avec la
réforme de retraites elle fasse arrêter
moins rapidement cette carrière là donc
ça ce sont des dossiers qui sont
essentiels et il va pas juste falloir
donner un petit coup de de pommade ou de
mots clés pour pouvoir venir à bout
justement de cette colère parce qu'à une
vraie colère sociale chez les médecins
chez les infirmières mais maintenant
chez les patients on voit que la santé
cds préoccupation numéro une et il
s'agit pas simplement de dire ne vous
inquiétez pas tout va bien se passer et
vous aurez plus de justice parce que je
pense que ça passera pas comme ça
merci beaucoup d'être venu réagir sur
notre plateau gérald dunkerbeck médecin
urgentiste